[musique]
9ème
maintenant la moitié
Est arrivé
qu'un
fais-le
[ __ ] merci mahendragarh
Très bientôt
fais-le
[musique]
à Ajay
Un blog comparatif est venu s'installer sur moins
Cette réaction a été très élevée dans le système
Ki et bonjour 15620
Le mode économie est désactivé jusqu'à demain soir mais aussi parce que
Chaque notification manquée est désormais classée à l'approche de la fin
l'eau a besoin d'un
[Appréciation]
fais-le
Je ne sais pas ce qui se passera après ça, mais nous
Je suis très blessé que notre
Quoi qu’il arrive, nous en recevions quelques-uns.
Beaucoup de gens sont également partis maintenant et
C'est encore nous, peut-être que nous avons du travail à faire
Cela ne sert à rien de travailler comme ouvrier comme nous le faisions auparavant.
Fera du mal à l'avenir également et sur d'autres plateformes
J'essaierai également d'ajouter cela
Juste après avoir rejoint beaucoup de
que la vie change
C'est très bien à cause de ça jusqu'à Z
Nous avons obtenu la plateforme parce que nous étions femmes au foyer.
Où irez-vous faire des vidéos tout en étant assis à la maison?
Présentez votre talent au monde entier
Nous aurions pu le faire comme je l’ai fait avant tout le monde.
Je ne pouvais pas parler sans être dérangé par mon travail
Je travaillais et j'étais comme une femme au foyer à mon âge.
Un bon sens devant même parmi les étrangers
Regardez attentivement et voyez le problème du compteur d’eau.
Je n'ai tellement confiance qu'à travers les billets
Aujourd'hui, je suis venu vous parler également par type.
Est-ce que je l'obtiens ou un autre centre personnel?
Je peux aussi donner
fais-le
[musique]
Est arrivé
à Ajay